Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No promising to make
people into Magical Girls!
Listen, lots of us have dreamed of becoming
heroes with magical powers, fighting for love,
truth, and justice, and battling evil in a
pretty dress!
I know I have.
But don't let Dr. Bright trick you into thinking
he's able to dispense that kind of power.
The amulet is not a "soul gem," nor is it
imbued with any supernatural powers that can
be connected to the moon or any of the planets
in our solar system.
Don't trust him, even if he promises to include
a "magical girl outfit."
That sounds...creepy.
If he says that to you, spray him with some
pepper spray.